acrid smoke fills the air as  firefighters  battle to save the ship health officials  in san diego have warned residents who  smell smoke to stay indoors  dozens of people have been treated for  smoke inhalation and heat exhaustion  but another danger is looming almost 4  million liters of oil are aboard the uss  bonhomme richard  a containment barrier has been installed  as a precaution  one of the navy's worst shipyard fires  in recent years  the superstructure in the upper decks  continued to burn and have sustained  damage  the ford mass has collapsed and the ship  is lifting however  the watering is in progress and we're  keeping a good balance between both  the admirals said the blaze appears to  have started in an area where cardboard  boxes and cloths were being stored  the vessels fire suppression system was  turned off  due to maintenance work the amphibious  assault ship is capable of deploying  thousands of marines her loss would be a  blow  for the u.s navy  you